how do you define free speech I Define  free speech I suppose as the founding  fathers might have defined Free Speech  or even as John Locke the father of  liberalism might have defined Free  Speech which is not totally free which  is yes we have broad Toleration for lots  of different things but there are limits  and they're pretty severe limits I mean  let's not forget we're not only talking  about speech acts like fraud or direct  threats or obscenity or things like that  people a lot of people don't even think  of obscenity these days as something not  protected by Free Speech but I would go  further than that all right yes it's  true that the libs have speech codes but  chivalry is a speech code too you know  and I'm all for chivalry I'm all for  Banning people who are degrading our  society